we both have something in common
you have a daughter named
frankie
i have a daughter named frankie i know
you do
i know now how old is your frankie
she is um gonna be eight next month um
okay and um her sister olive is going to
be 10. how old is your frankie
my frankie is 13. and then you have a uh
15 or
yeah i have a 15 year old boy as well
yes is it true that um frankie like left
you a note in your backpack once tell
will you tell me that story yeah
yeah she um i was going on a trip i was
going to uh on location or something i
was gonna be gone for a couple weeks and
as i was walking out the door she said
daddy i wrote you a note um i put it in
your backpack you can't open it and read
it until you're on the plane
so i was like oh my god yeah of course
this is incredible and
got on the plane and
and waited till we were in the air and i
opened it found this little envelope and
was just so excited wanted to turn
around and tell everyone that i have a
daughter who writes me notes
and puts them in my bed you know it was
all just i was so
happy and i opened this little note and
it's it's in an envelope and it's just a
a post-it that's been folded in half and
i open it and it says you suck
[Laughter]
so it's pranky frankie
yeah pranky frankie is right that's
really good oh yeah cranky frankie
frankie pranky and is it true that your
parents were like
a little liberal with swearing when you
were a kid is this true
that's right uh my mom was uh
when we were in her house not only me
but any friends i had around from like
elementary school on we could say
whatever we wanted
and uh and so whenever my friends would
come
over they would walk in and they'd be
like hey you anne and she'd be like
and she'd say similar things back to
them and they just loved it loved it so
much do you know actually a funny thing
that happened when our son graham was in
kindergarten he walked up to his
kindergarten teacher and told her that
he has a headache
and what did the teacher do
she she just said oh okay well we'll get
you um some aspen or something but also
that word we just don't say it at school
but then she couldn't wait to pull naomi
and i aside and tell us what happened
she thought it was hilarious she was
really cool okay so is it true that you
pictured yourself in a steven spielberg
movie when you were a kid we could have
been there together oh yeah oh my god
it's all i thought about ever since
raiders lost dark i mean
people have to understand that in that
era
steven spielberg movies were coming out
like every year almost and they were all
amazing and world-changing like you know
raiders and then e.t just
what two years later and a year later
something like that
um yeah et was a movie that i went to
see over and over and over again and
ended up being the first movie i went to
by myself
i
asked my mom like what if i went to see
it again
but just me because i had got i brought
everyone in my family all of my friends
everyone had seen it with me and but i
needed to see it
again so i just rode my bike to the
theater went and watched it
finished got on my bike and rode home
and i was so like proud of myself uh
for for doing that but also
it sort of opened up this whole other
world of enjoying movies by yourself and
it being an important part of the
experience is what you what you take
from it
personally and for you
[Music]
you